okay so I'll talk briefly about the
program on on data privacy that's
running right now this semester so it's
one of two spring 2019 programs our
organizers are myself I'm Adam Smith
from Boston you vitaly Feldman from
Google Katrina Liggett Kobi Nasim and
Sasha Slav kovitch so the and and I
guess there's one more organizer who his
name doesn't appear here because
unfortunately he passed away after about
a year and a half ago but after this
program was conceived and his Steve
Feinberg who was a statistician an
eminent statistician at CMU so the
context for the program of course is
that you know data and data driven
systems or guiding decisions in in many
areas of society and the way in which
this is happening is increasingly
complex and we are constantly
confronting questions of balancing and
somehow understanding how to get the
benefits of these these enormous data
sets that we're collecting and and the
benefits of the systems that use them
while under trying to understand and
mitigate the various negative
consequences that can come along with
those the costs in terms of privacy also
things like transparency control
fairness so all really this program is
really focusing on the sort of the
privacy part although these other things
can't come in incidentally and there's a
whole other program that Cynthia will
talk about going on this summer focusing
on transparency and fairness but in a
nutshell the question for the program is
how we can make statistically useful
information so about sensitive datasets
broadly available in a way that's
responsible so when I say sensitive I
mean containing sensitive data and what
statistically useful of course will vary
from application to application but just
broadly as useful as possible
so this is the program it's a this is an
institute for theoretical computer
science a lot of the program is focused
on fundamental theoretical questions
developing algorithmic tools lower
bounds understanding fundamental limits
of various frameworks for thinking
reasoning about privacy and duty
analyzing data privately but there's
also a strong component of interactions
between the technical work and law and
policy and ethical questions with flow
going in both directions we have a
number of participants I'll talk about
in a second coming from these areas and
we're really trying to understand to
what extent technical notions can inform
how we formulate policy for example in
to what extent sort of the various
consensus is that different parts of
society have arrived at if for what you
know what is important about privacy in
a given scenario info should inform
technical work and we're looking at
applications in a number of areas
especially in the Social and Behavioral
Sciences although other areas as well we
have 30 long-term participants who are
here on a regular basis throughout the
semester either full-time in residence
or coming on a regular basis from other
parts of the Bay Area a junior fellows a
whole pile of graduate students plus
other participants who are here on a
sort of short-term basis background you
get people from a number of areas within
theoretical computer science and there's
a bulk of the participants of course but
also we have we have a number of people
from statistics ranging in their focus
from more applied to more theoretical
questions people with backgrounds and
applications in the social sciences
questions about law and policy we have a
number of lawyers who are here as part
of the program
and you know people who think about
ethics and questions of sort of trying
to formulate to what extent we are
capturing various important like
socially important concepts in these
technical so
stones and it's intentional that these
bubbles kind of overlap because as you
men might imagine certainly between
statistics and computer science there's
a fair amount of overlapping in terms of
tease and thought processes but to some
extent with all of these bubbles so just
to give you a sense of the kinds of
questions that are coming up in the
program and I'm not you know I only have
a few minutes so just I just have like a
few you know some questions it may be
representative problems that people are
thinking about you know it on one end
we're looking at very precise
mathematical questions one of the
concepts that plays a central role in
the program is differential privacy not
not the only one but like the kind of
questions we ask there might be you know
given a well-formed statistical
hypothesis testing question you know
what what is the optimal differentially
private test how do we how do we analyze
the the and characterize the structure
of the right estimation procedures and
things like that what are the accuracy
limits of differentially private
optimization this has come up a lot and
in the industrial work on differential
privacy in the context of you know
fitting neural networks to sensitive
data also reasoning about like whether
or not the definitions we have for a
given context are adequate are perhaps
being too conservative and so when or
and or when or when are they not so when
are they're realizable attacks that sort
of demonstrate the failures of some of
these rigorous formulations and when or
they're not when it when is there a kind
of a gray zone where we have neither
working attacks nor kind of anyway
rigorous way to analyze things and those
are obviously places where we look for
no interesting problems various
questions that come up about our key
architectures for distributed data
analysis so for example you know
companies like Google and Apple
currently have deployed systems or
they're trying to analyze sensitive data
that's held on user devices they're not
the only companies doing this what are
the different ways to organize those
systems that make sense either for one
company or perhaps a collection of
organizations not just like companies
and we're looking a lot at applications
in first
mystical agencies and specifically the
the US Census Bureau which is currently
modernizing its disclosure limitation
methodology and so like a typical you
know an example of a question that came
up in the last week and that we were
talking about actively sort of what
would it take for the US Census Bureau
to provide a useful Verte synthetic data
version of what is what it used to be
called the long term census forms though
so it's called the American Community
Survey so they're really detailed
questions they ask a subset of the of
the US population and you know some of
these discussions have focused both on
the practical aspects but also just just
trying to formulate these questions in
ways that are precise enough that we can
sort of get a community of people
working on them rather than just a small
number of people inside the bureau and
just on another tack what kind of
economic frameworks make sense for say
cooperative management of sensitive data
anyway so one thing that has garnered
some attention recently I think is
called data coops that this is sort of a
collective effort on the part of many
individuals to manage data and and gain
value from the from their data what are
the economic frameworks and also what
are the legal frameworks that that come
to play these are this is another you
know example of the flavor of quite a
question comes up so you see a fair
variety of different types of questions
that require a fairly broad selection of
areas and expertise to answer and that's
what we tried to bring together
[Applause]
questions oh yes I didn't define that so
differential privacy is a specific
restriction so the context it it is for
is if you've got a sensitive data set
about which you want to publish
information it's a specific technical
framework for thinking about how much
information about any one individual is
leaked in by that sort of by those by
the output of the system and it it's
sort of a it's a condition on the on the
system that processes a mathematical
restriction on the the algorithm that
processes the the data and so roughly
what it requires is that if for any
change in one person's data the induced
change on the probability distribution
of the outputs of the system be very
small and so it's a it's a condition
that's reasonably easy to write down and
specify but and it's it has become a
fairly well I mean certainly well
studied and in many contexts the
standard notion of technical notion of
privacy but there are many lots of
technical questions that remain about
the best way to design algorithms that
satisfy this restriction when we can't
know what their limitations are that
sort of thing
other questions
thanks very much
[Applause]